okay so at the beginning right we had
this kind of static stance and then you
come in and kick that drust KCK all
right this one's going to be a little
bit more Dynamic so I don't want you to
kick your hardest cuz they're not going
to be in a good stance is the bag holder
make sure the bag's close to you and you
do have some down pressure okay um so I
he's going to be let me let me use the
bag the B holder key on this
okay so I'm like somebody that is
squaring up on him and when he sees the
square target and me entering that's
when he's going to deliver that thrust
kick okay on the back leg so uh I'm kind
of ging it but you can see that I'm
moving around and when he's ready he
throws that okay just let it
absorb and you get another rep at
it he has to land back in his good
base okay all right here we go that's
the so again on the on the roundhouse
kick strong to the leg we taught his
static he goes and I can absorb that
okay because I'm I don't know what
stance I'm going to be in when I get in
what he considers the mod for that kick
you got to kind of pull it back a little
bit okay so so mean what I'm going to do
is I'm going to try to keep the back as
opposed to my knee do you do you see
that I try to keep the back okay and I
gave him that and as he feels me get
into the r he he won't try to break my
leg okay but it's still decent enough
power as we're doing it so I'm cir and
when I get
in and if you can try to get your weight
off of that foot as as early as possible
so that the two don't make you know
gasoline and fire okay so he's staying
with me not let me angle on him
and okay all right here we go the the
we'll do the first one the front kick
okay so as I'm doing this front kick and
he moves into range I have to find that
ground path so it's not that I'm over
here
and trying to use a different Force
engine it it's the same ground grounding
okay you can't come off of that and the
same thing goes on the round kick okay
I'm not going to start getting torque in
here and and trying to get rotational
torque this this foot is going to plant
and boom I'm kicking through the mass
okay cuz whatever I wanted a minimum
aside from injury is his mass is no
longer staying in place it has to be
displaced okay so make sure you you're
establishing the ground VOR on the
planted foot all right continue